bonjour pascal lopez merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france votre réaction tout
d'abord à ce plan social sanofi qui
maintient son plan d'économies malgré
les bénéfices
un énième plan et 38 ans je suis dans
cette entreprise
mon quatorzième plan social c'est à dire
une moyenne à maxi s'implante les trois
ans nous sortons déjà d'un plan social
qui a été vécu assez difficilement par
mes collègues on avait supprimé
récemment dans le cadre d'une rupture
consommée collectif dans la déprime ans
r 1200 emplois 600 voudras entité où je
me trouve donc ils sont des fonctions
support de du groupe et on nous annonce
la même chose cette fois ci donc mille
suppressions d'emplois faire débat la
base de départs volontaires
mais la problématique et relation simple
c'est que les salariés sont bons mais la
charge de travail restent les conditions
de travail se dégradent et on a des
salariés si on prend les traits puisque
nous avons vécu très récemment 3-6 6-1
suicide le 5 octobre à nantes le 9 mai
et un autre le dixel j'en ai cinq
minutes de l'est la mort sur le site
besantini des sites les plus importants
de talent et qui donc ce que je
comprends c'est que les cadences sont de
plus en plus soutenue alors que le
groupe
licencié il ya cent mille salariés dans
le monde
un millier de deux postes supprimés en
france pourquoi la france
particulièrement selon vous je ne sais
pas si la france
écoute vous verrez comme un temps de
coûts plus importants que les autres
pays qui est certain c'est que
systématiquement la france fait partie
des pays qui paye le prix du loyer des
rares des minéraux la difficulté au tour
n'a aujourd'hui c'est que on n'a pas une
vraie vision
on ne peut imaginer la vision
stratégique de l'entreprise
nous on a une idée assez à ses stars et
ses claire de ce que la direction de le
faire
mais c'est directement et toi ne veut
pas communiquer sur le sujet ou ne peut
pas communiquer sur le sujet nous on
pense que derrière ce projet énième
projet de réorganisation des
suppressions massives d'emplois il ya
autre chose
on vient de fêter toutes nos parts dans
une société américaine s'appellerait
générons pas rapporter quelque chose
sonne 17 milliards d'euros
cette entreprise est la septième est
tombé de la cinquième place à la 7ème
place au niveau mondial
je pense qu'elle n'a qu'un objectif
c'est de reconquérir à sa 102e place
dans la classification mondiale et le
tribut à payer pour arriver à cet
objectif
c'est aussi de se servir comme nord à
variable d'ajustement
le personnel de l'entreprise on sait
qu'en soient les conséquences qu'on voit
bien non l'alerté les salariés à la
direction sur le sort des salariés
depuis maintenant des années l alerte le
droit d'aller à ce qu'on a on vient de
voter au niveau du comité
le cse s'est assagi on aille vers saint
ambroise a l'air pur danger imminent
pichard la santé des salariés n'est que
l'aboutissement d'années
il alerte on a demandé en octobre une
enquête sur un décès est suspect tout à
l'heure en acide
on avait un navet rapport qui accable
est la responsabilité d'entreprise
notamment ce qu'on appelle l'évaluation
des performances et le fait que les
salaires étaient insuffisamment
accompagnés à partir à chaque
réorganisation à chaque projet de
sous-traitance
on a énormément qui prêtait d'activité
dans cette entreprise fui dans les cinq
dernières années
tous les métiers sont touchés tous les
métiers sont suscite ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on remplace des salariés
en cdi par des salariés s'y prêtant par
des intérimaires par demain des contrats
de chantier puisque maintenant fêter ce
site dans notre compte mon sens qu est
il est tout à ces la précarisation des
salariés c'est un moment le retrouve
totalement désespéré par rapport à nous
pour vous c'est c'est la course au
profit qui prime on sait que ça nous
fait bien
a u 7 % de hausse de son chiffre
d'affaires au premier trimestre déjà en
grande partie la moitié du grâce aux
qu'ovide on a vu ces médicaments à
l'image grasse également les dividendes
en plus son sont bien plus conséquent
que l'an dernier ils ont été
redistribuées la 9 milliards exactement
2 4 milliards de dividendes une note
milliards 9 milliards pour le chiffre
d'affaires pour n'augmenter seront
peut-être pour prendre le premier side
est donc une entreprise avec une marge
opérationnelle qui fait pâlir d'envié
beaucoup d'entreprises celles qu'elle
soit avec des projets de de marge
opérationnelle qui sont entre 25 et 30%
c'est ça aussi le projet qui est sur la
table c'est à dire que non seulement de
réduire les délais techniques nous ont
augmenté encore plus nomads et être pas
forcément au détriment et évidemment on
se souvient de cette polémique de la
vente de vaccins aux privilégiés pour
les états unis l'état français avait dû
intervenir pour vous clairement c'est
une course au profit
que fait heins sanofi de la première à
tiques des vaccins qui nous promet
actifs différents pronostics de ce tour
de financement
pas vraiment envie d'entrer sur le sujet
parce que je fais que l'état l'état
quand il a été sollicité n'a pas accepté
les demandes du laboratoire pas plus que
l'europe
d'où le fait que sanofi se soit retourné
dans les américains et que les
américains aient accepté la visite est
contre le fait il voulait avoir la
priorité de la fourniture des vaccins
je compte alors les istres et courra les
ziani par contre par contre là où nous
on n'est plus d'accord
c'est une entreprise réorganisée qu'elle
était de trouver un mode de
fonctionnement si mal c'est la vie de
l'entreprise
là où on n'est plus d'accord du tout
c'est que ça se passe temps au respecté
les fondamentaux d'une entreprise à
savoir le permettre à ses salariés
d'évoluer correctement leur permettre de
pouvoir adapter leur emploi via la
formation ne pas se retrouver seul face
à un pack d'emplois quand on réorganise
ne pas se trouver seule frappe a pas de
problème notamment en où les valeurs
sont la performance que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure c'est partie des gens qui ont
dénoncé un système de rente si force est
dans notre
entreprise il ya trois ans on a
découvert qu'il y avait des salariés qui
étaient prêts notez en début d'année
donc c'est évidemment avec une ni deux
cents personnes qui devaient être
licenciés
ça m'a été fournie par mes collègues on
l'a démontée dans la radio et on n'y a
ni chat mais on voit bien qu un
processus dans cette entreprise à un
système à système ce qui est assez
cynique
voilà et qui se soucie assez peu de la
santé des uns et des autres alors c'est
son métier c'est son coeur de métier non
c'est le coeur de métier les le peu
d'entrain de citer les tempêtes et les
français moi je devais faire un mauvais
du mondial les hauts faits c'est la
santé des salariés ou des actionnaires
bon a priori je pense que ce soit était
fait maintenant oui quand on quand on
privilégie des versements foncière de
dividendes à ses actionnaires
et qu'on le faire au détriment de la
santé
lorsque l'on parle de la santé oms
palpable des salaires des conditions
pareilles de l'emploi non par de la
tempe et c'est l'infini sanofi dit que
ce n est pas un plan social c'est une
nouvelle stratégie on le sait quelques
pans de la recherche seraient sacrifiés
notamment sur le diable est enfin est ce
que c'est ça véritablement selon que on
peut l'appeler comme on veut derrière
pdci traitement emplois massives
moi je fais que dans mon activité
identité ça va être encore autour de 400
postes supprimés
faisant suite à 600 postes supprimés
précédemment et des centaines y faire ça
n'arrête plus voir on enchaîne les plans
sociaux le club social précédent et
détente et arrêté le 30 juin et on nous
annonce aujourd'hui un nouveau plan
total d'heures que le plan social ne
s'est même pas terminé on est déjà en
train de briller sur un second
merci lazcano voilà merci pascal obèses
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur rt
france